Apple's HealthKit demonstrates the growing importance of AM Health.
HealthKit stores data from iPhone and Apple Watch apps and from
some devices in an encrypted database called the HealthKit store.
The data is only accessible via the health app,
through which users can view, add, delete,
and otherwise manage all of their health and fitness data.
Importantly, as shown here,
they can control fine grained permissions for the sharing of each data type.
Users must explicitly grant each app permission
to read from and write data to the HealthKit store.
Users can grant or deny permission separately for each type of data.
For example, a user can allow an app to read their step count,
but prevent it from reading their blood glucose level.
To prevent possible information leaks,
an app does not know about denials and from the app's point of view,
data for which it lacks read permission does not exist.
Once an app has been granted permission to access data in the store,
it can use OpenAM Health's Granola tool to store it on a remote server for analysis or
backup or to serialize the data which is
only stored in the HealthKit store for a limited period of time.
Granola maps and validates the HealthKit API to OpenAM Health's HealthKit JSON schemas.
Here's an example of that for step_count data from HealthKit
converted by Granola into OpenAM Health compliant JSON.